Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to another episode of Cutters,
clinic life podcast. Dr. Carpell, you have a very unique practice. You see people that have
cancer and you see people that have other health conditions, but you do things as far as,
you know, how you treat a disease very different than what we do. So I was really excited to talk
to you today and get your perspective on other therapies that people can utilize that. I tell you
when you want the sub of the therapies that we're going to talk about that you do, they're very
few people that are doing stuff like this. You are very unique. So tell me a little bit more about
you. Well, thank you so much, Dr. Connors. And yeah, I'm really excited that the therapies we offer,
there aren't that many United States that do it. It is what I would consider kind of at the
forefront of of integrative oncology along with a lot of the things that, you know, that we've
done for a while that we know are tried and true. Myself, I'm a naturopathic doctor. I've been
practicing for been in clinical practice for 35 years, you know, since 1987. I've seen hundreds of
thousands of patient interactions since then. I've done a couple of TV shows, you know, one that you
can find right now on 2B TV, true health, with true health by the mind spirit with Dr. Carlefeld.
I have current laws to do a couple of podcasts, you know, the one on integrative line solutions with
Dr. Carlefeld, integrative cancer solutions with Dr. Carlefeld where we talk to people that
have gone through using integrative therapies then to resolve these different issues, you know,
cancer in line, which can be really difficult, obviously. And we run a larger integrative clinic
where we combine them both medical and also naturopathic and do, you know, IVs. We have hyperbaric,
we do the photodynamic, we do a lot of detox strategies. And so it's fun, it's powerful
when you combine it all. And also, I feel that you can layer the therapies together to address
things, you know, from all around, because cancer is such a complex disease. And so it is important
that you look at it from all different angles. Well, could we talk about some of them specifically?
I think photodynamic therapy is something that our bad nurse asks about fairly frequently.
So could you explain that to a person exactly what that is and how they would use it?
Yeah, absolutely. So photodynamic is something's been around for a long time. But it's only been
used externally, meaning that a person has a melanoma, then use a photosensitizing agent. And I'll
talk a little bit more about that. But you apply that and it absorbs into the cancer cells and then
you expose that tumor to light, to laser light. And that triggers oxidation within the cancer cells
so that you kill the cancer cell. And so the issue is that it's that it has been limited to just
external tumors. So what we've been working on is then utilizing this technology and been able
them to get enough saturation of photosensitizers in tumors that are inside the body. And then also
being able them to get laser delivery, light delivery into the tumors that are also inside the bodies.
You know, let's say that you're dealing with lung or you're dealing with pancreatic or liver or
breast or wherever it may be. So then we then have a certain kind of photosensitizer that has been
developed as a good friend of mine in Germany that has developed this at the university that he's in.
And that it's a nononized form of ICG in an in Sinine green. And the beauty with that one is that
it attracts infrared light. So it pulls infrared light into wherever it's at. So we can introduce that
intravenously. And then also we can if we have access to the tumor, we can then inject it around the
tumor to create saturation within the tumor of this photosensitizer. But also when we introduce it
intravenously, it will then actually travel because the tumors have a certain type of
vascularity. Their blood vessels are very disorganized, they're leaky. And that allows an actual
dissaturation to take place within the tumor of the photosensitizer. And this specific one
doesn't flush out that hangs out in the body for like 10 days, 10 to 14 days. And it gives us a
window of time that we can then treat the tumor because we know that the tumor is getting a
saturation. And we can then introduce an intravenous light to treat the cancer cells that are
floating by in the circulatory system, like the circulating tumor cells or cancer stem cells.
So we can tag them and then treat the mass and pass them by in addition to them using a very
specific type of laser system, or we can even use little optic needles with the laser, you know,
optic fiber inside so we can then target the tumor with with these lasers.
So let's say an example like a breast cancer that might be several centimeters underneath the surface
of a skin, you could do an injectable photosensitized agent. And then you would you just laser the
surface at that point or would you do those, would you do the laser that would be basically injected
as well? How would you do that? Yeah, so you can do both, you know, because then you have good access,
you know, it's different if you have something in the liver, you know, you don't want to stick a needle
into the liver. But if you have like a breast or something that is easily accessible or sarcoma
that is kind of in the leg or, you know, that is easier to access, and then you can then bring these
needles, you know, that you have an optic fiber and go through the skin barrier and then get close
to the tumor and then laser that from different angles at the same time using these optic fibers.
And we can turn that laser up to, you know, to the comfort of the patient. But so you
anesthetize the area and then you bring the fiber optic cables in there and then to kind of get a
strong concentration of that light of that laser light into that area because that has been one of
the issues in the past that we didn't have the technology to be able to deliver a strong enough laser
light, you know, saturation because the skin barrier will will stop a lot of penetration
and using what has been used in past has been mostly red and red only goes so deep. Infrared goes
quite a bit deeper and if we can then kind of bypass the skin barrier as well with the optic needle
using then the infrared, we have then a deeper penetration to trigger that oxidative response.
Then how many treatments would, let's say, a breast cancer, this example, how many treatments
would that person go through that 14 days at that? So during the 14 days we usually want to do it at
least but four times. So twice a week is what we tend to do with the optic needles and then we use
an external as well and that is done every day, you know, so we want to create as much and we
we combine that also we have laser bed, you know, that's really powerful that that delivers about
1800 watts, you know, so it's really potent and then we combine that with like hyperbaric oxygen
therapy and then also have another machine called a hockey. Because you want oxygen in the tumor
in order to be able to oxidize the cell and so it is important then that we use things like,
you know, a hyperbaric to create a saturation of oxygen within the tumor so we can trigger that
oxidation. Okay, how it like that we talked about that example of breast cancer, how about an example
of a more internal tumor like a colon cancer? So if it's a colorectal, then then we have an easy
access there. So then we have done a another type of laser, it's kind of like a little kind of
bold delivery that you can then insert directly so that we can deliver strong concentration of light
in that area. But if it is then higher up, you know, let's say it is in the transfers or in the
the sigmoid area, I mean, I'm sorry, in the illiosecal area, yeah, then we then we need to do it then
kind of externally, yeah, at that point, but it's so close to the skin surface there so that we
are with the infrared, we're able to get a good delivery still. Okay, well that's really encouraging.
Pancreatic cancer, same thing you're going to do an external approach on that.
Yes, yes, exactly. Yeah, we yeah, the same thing, yeah, we don't want to stick a needle into something
we can damage in any way. So yeah, first do no harm. Yeah, so we have I mean, we have people in
the city that might live in Florida or New York or something. Would they schedule with you and fly out
there and you know, plan on spending two, three weeks to do this particular therapy, you might choose
to add other things that we would be able to talk about today too. Yeah, so usually what would it
looks like, you know, patient would would call and we'll do like a 15, 15 minute kind of free
discovery call where we just cannot save. So I get a feeling for the patient that you had a feeling
for me and I see, you know, if this is a good fit with what we're doing and if it is, then we schedule
then a longer initial where I can then develop more of a of an extensive protocol and after that,
then we have patient, they fly in and they use typically stay here for about two weeks, you know,
sometimes a little bit longer about typically is about two weeks and they receive them the the
photodynamic therapy, along with other things, you know, like high dose vitamin C, artisanate IV,
curcumin IV, polyMVA, DCA, mistletoe, and then we also use another type of therapy IV therapy
where we actually extract the patient's platelets and then we load them with the photosensitizing agents
and mistletoe and also we'll use a methylene blue, which is another synth or photosensitizer.
And then we so we load their platelets and then we micro do a micro filtration process which makes
these platelets into kind of a nono delivery system, which allows them to to travel into any kind of
location, the body, you know, through any kind of barrier and they will then have and they're drawn
towards areas of inflammation, cancer obviously is an inflammatory condition. So it will then be drawn
to the tumor micro environment and then offload whatever it is that we have kind of loaded into
these platelets, you know, whether it's a photosensitizer, mistletoe, artisanate or curcumin or whatever it
may be that we have. What is that you just described? What is that therapy called? So we call it platelet
and derived nonaparticle delivery. Wow, that's fascinating, fascinating information. Now everybody's
wondering what that microscope over your right shoulder is used for. So I'll explain how you look
at blood. Yeah, yeah, so I love this little device here and this is how we can look at, you know,
like take a cancer patient, for instance, you know, or I've had other patients where I look at the
blood and say, well, you really should have somebody look, you know, concerned that there may be cancer
that we're dealing with. So you look, you take a drop of blood and you can look at underslide and
look at the microscope and you can then see the behavior and the quality of the red blood cells,
white blood cells, you can see kind of fun, if their fungus there, you can see parasites,
you can see, you know, the healthy, how healthy the membranes are of the red blood cells,
how able it is to transport oxygen, you can also see liver patterns and kidney patterns,
colon patterns. So it's a lot of information you can gain just by looking at a drop of blood from
an individual, and then you can then also then use the dry, so you have another slide where you
kind of do a dropping, you kind of hit the slide several times, so you have different drops and
throughout the sliding, you can allow that then to dry, it's called a, remember to forget the name,
dry blood, yeah, microscopy, and so there you can then see the coagulatory patterns in the blood
and see the tissue integrity, see if there's a lot of inflammation, you can see if a person is very
deficient and like vitamin C, you know, the first drop, you see like a vitamin C ring, you can see
also kind of heart patterns, you know, if a person has a little bit issues with the heart, you can see
that, you can see prostate, you can see colon, if there's inflammation, the colon, you can see
spanish, I mean, there's a huge amount of different things that you can see based upon just the patterns
of the blood, and then you can direct the type of care that an individual would need based upon
what you see, I mean, how they're digesting protein, how they, I mean, all of these things are,
they're anemic, if they, yeah, it's really, really fascinating, the amount of information,
then you, you can then follow up and you do an intervention, you do therapy, and you can then follow
up and see does it look better? Are we, are we doing a good job or not a good job? And what do we need
to change? Directive data before it after. Yeah, exactly. No, just so, our listeners know that this
is, some of these therapies you're talking about, certainly, live blood cell analysis like your,
like your microscope is not legal in a lot of states. It's certainly not legal in Minnesota,
and I don't believe in Wisconsin. So, in a lot of states about a lot, it's just the medical
tyranny that we're living under currently is not getting any better. So you need to travel to
people who have experience doing this. Could you give us a little plug on where you are again
and your website, how people will find you, you know, we'll have it up here, but I want people to
know. Yeah, so I'm, I'm in Boise, Idaho, actually in Meridian, Idaho, which is just a kind of
a suburb of the Boise, and it is the capital of Idaho. It's a beautiful state. Obviously, we have
winters like you have. But, yeah, you've got beautiful mountains. We have beautiful rivers
during the summer. You know, people can float the river. And so, yeah, it's, it's a beautiful town. I'm
me originally, I'm from Sweden. Yeah, so, yeah, exactly. So I initially moved and had my practice in
California on Santa Monica for many, many years. And obviously, I wanted to get away from big city.
I mean, I love the beach. I loved, loved all of that. But the, the freedom of being able to do what
I do is, is more accessible here in Idaho than it would be in California. Like you're talking about
the nutritional might or the, the light blood cell analysis. I know in Washington, it's not legal.
I don't think it's legal in California either if I remember right. So, so Boise is Idaho is a
little bit more freedom-loving. So, so I've been here for 20 years. And, yeah, you can find me on
the carl, at the carlfieldcenter.com. So it's the, and then my last name, then center.com.
Have a huge amount of resources there. I've done, used to have a radio show called Health Made Radio,
where I've interviewed, you know, I've ran that for about three, three years. I interviewed a ton of
people that are leaders, you know, like Dr. Paul Anderson or Natia Winters or Neil Nathan or, you know,
so it's a lot of different leaders in their field. And, and I'm upset that I didn't get a hold of you,
you know, before I quit the show. I wanted to interview on that as well. But we, we have the summit where
people get to kind of really hear how awesome you are and what you do. So, so that, you know, it's a
huge, huge amount of resources that you find there. I have a, a free ebook you can get there. It's
called 11 things when diagnosed, you know, 11 things to address when diagnosed with cancer. You know,
going through 11 things are really important to look at so that you can then create a whole program
to address what's going on, rather than just doing one thing and thinking that that's enough. So,
so it's all there on my website. Well, I love what you do. I love just the things that you're talking
about right now are things that you can't find everywhere. And people think you have to go down to
the Mexico clinics or something to get these things. And I'll tell you, there's a lot of people that are
very skeptical about traveling across the border and stayed there and what they're actually going to
get. And the cost can be astronomical to go down there now. I really, we're going to get your
information up on our member site so people can have other options. And this is just such a blessing.
I'm so glad that we're able to talk to you. Could we have you want to get it? You can share more
information and more stuff that you do. Absolutely. I know your time is valuable and precious to you.
We want to get people to know you more and make your time more valuable and more precious to you. I
guess. Well, I appreciate this opportunity a lot. And yeah, I appreciate I appreciate everything
that you're doing. And we need, I mean, to have these these pillars that are emanating or that
dispersing good information, good foundational principles. And because a lot of times it is,
I kind of like in cancer therapy. I mean, yes, you can do all these different fancy things. But if
you don't have the foundational things, then you can't get anywhere. And and it is important like
that we all can keep communicating about the foundation. All you good, good eating, good mindset,
good exercise, good movement. And then bringing in detoxification, bringing in all these different
factors that are that are key. And by setting those right and having that as a foundation,
then you can take the next step to these more, the kind of fancy, I would say, more heroic type of
treatment that we do here. Yeah, that's fantastic. Well, thank you so much, Dr. Michael,
Carfeldt, and Boise Idaho. We are going to have your information up on our site. I know where
listeners are going to be really pleased to hear all that you do just having it option in the US
is just fantastic. Yeah, well, thank you. And I do when I do a shout out also for the summit that we
have that I've interviewed you on a regenerative medicine summit that will air January 10th,
which would be fantastic summit. So yeah, so that would be fantastic way for people to get the
information as well. So thank you so much for having me. I appreciate this.
All right. Well, we'll talk again very soon. Thank you so much. That'd be great. Thanks so much.
Bye-bye.